so if you like me have never watched
the bachelor and are still a little bit
confused about what the bachelor
even is and are sure only that whatever
it is
it's certainly entertainment for people
with the iq of uh maybe a squid or
something
if this describes you then you have
missed the probably the latest
controversy surrounding the show
i bring it to your attention now as it
was brought to my attention only because
it's so
it's so perfectly emblematic of where we
are
as a culture so now try to try to follow
this story because it gets a little gets
a little twisty
uh rachel kurt connell or maybe it's
kirk cannell
not sure is we'll go with kurt cannell
because it sounds fancier rachel kirk
cannell is a contestant on the latest
season of the bachelor
vying for the heart of one matt james
the contestants are all trying to uh
actually marry him
i think that's how it works anyway matt
james is a black man
and that shouldn't be relevant that
shouldn't matter but of course race is
always made relevant by the left these
days
it came out recently that rachel has a
history of racist
behavior and by racist behavior we mean
principally that she attended a frat
party
in 2018 with an antebellum south
theme and pictures from this gathering
uh
resurfaced as they say and she can be
seen
wearing a white hood and um uh with a
with a pointy top and lighting a cross
on fire so
no sorry actually never mind that's not
what the picture shows at all
no in the pictures she's wearing a pink
frilly dress
and and taking a selfie with her friends
that's it
antebellum as it turns out is not latin
for
racist or clan member it actually means
literally
before the war anti-bellum
so the antebellum south is the south
before the civil war yes the south
before the civil war
had slavery that's true so did a huge
portion of the rest of the globe
at that time so when when college kids
go to an antebellum party
they're not going there to celebrate
slavery that's not the idea
they're going there to wear fun outfits
and most crucially
to drink copious amounts of alcohol
that's of course always the real
uh the real goal of any college party so
and this is clear to any reasonable
person
right but we're running a shortage of
those kinds of people today so the
controversy raged
internet sleuths started digging up
other suspicious
online activity from this uh this girl
edgy posts and
and photos the girls like the girl liked
and they dug up rumors
from her time in grade school uh and the
hunt was on
they were on the trail of another racist
or at least someone that they could
pretend
was racist it's the same story we've
played out we've seen play out a million
times before
and as part of that story we know that
the apology
always comes next right rachel kurt
cannell issued a groveling
begging apology actually calling herself
a racist
multiple times in in the apology and
pleading for forgiveness for the harm
and damage
that she'd caused by wearing a frilly
dress and taking a picture
of course no forgiveness was given it
never is and that's when things take a
turn
for the even more insane chris harrison
is apparently the host of the bachelor
uh or was the host
he's he's now stepped down um after his
own racism controversy stemming from the
racism controversy
surrounding rachel if you think that
that simply being the host
of the bachelor was the most
embarrassing thing that chris harrison
would ever do
get a load of this because it gets a lot
worse he appeared on an interview show
on extra tv with a woman named rachel
lindsay
during that interview um this was early
last week
he was asked about the rachel kirk
canal stuff and he rambled for a little
bit but his point was simply that
we should uh we should have some grace
for her and we shouldn't ruin her life
over this
and he tried very very hard to make a
reasonable point
without ever taking a firm position he
tried very hard in fact he uses the
phrase
i don't know about 50 different times
during this
short part of the interview and his
point seems to be
we should have grace for this girl but
also
i don't know who knows please don't be
mad at me
let's listen to a clip of that what are
your thoughts about
rachel kirknell and the allegations
attached to her
a couple of things first and foremost i
don't know i haven't talked to rachel
about it
and and this is again where we all need
to have a little grace a little
understanding a little compassion
because i've seen some stuff online
again this judge jury executioner thing
where people are just tearing this
girl's life apart and diving into like
her parents and her parents voting
record and what it's it's
unbelievably alarming to watch this
i haven't heard rachel speak on this yet
and until i actually hear this woman
have a chance
to speak who am i to say any of this my
guess
these girls got dressed up and went to a
party and had a great time they were 18
years old
now does that make it okay i don't know
rachel you tell me
again i am not the woke police there's
plenty of people
plenty of people who will do that for us
in this world right now
i don't know like do you do you go tear
all those places down
and and tear up the dirt and and dig
deep enough that it erases it i don't
know
um you know when you see san francisco
erasing lincoln
and erasing washington and erasing
people because of what they stood for
180 years ago
and again they may be right at the end
of the day i don't know i i'm just gonna
give her the grace
and the time to actually come out and
speak and then hopefully i'll even have
a chance to debate her and i know you
will for sure she'll go on
extra or go on your podcast and
hopefully you'll have a great talk with
her
i don't know who knows i don't know i
don't know
don't be mad don't hate me gee guys i
just think maybe sorta we shouldn't
ruin this girl's life because she went
to a party in 2018 i don't know
maybe maybe don't be mad at me
well guess what they were mad at him uh
because of that what you just heard
there
he was accused of racism too and now
he's stepped down
after issuing his own groveling apology
where he also
uh confesses to causing damage to people
even though he caused no damage to
anyone and admits his that his actions
were racist even though they weren't
in the lead up to him stepping down the
host of that interview rachel lindsay
complained
that uh that he used his privilege
during the interview
and all the bachelor contestants came
out against him
and his own girlfriend his girlfriend
told the media
that he was defending racism and it's
unacceptable
much of this after his apology and they
still all
lined up to throw him under the bus
because the apology is never enough
and this this is why i bring this story
up and i think it's worth reflecting on
we are way past the point of saying
simply that people these days are
unforgiving
or that they fail to forgive or they
fail to show grace
we are way past that we're at we're at a
point now
where forgiveness is ruled out
categorically
to even advocate for it
is a sin just as bad as whatever sin
you're saying should be forgiven
even if the original sin was no sin at
all which most of the time
it isn't see what this is really about
and has always been about is cultural
dominance
the woke police as chris harrison called
them in that interview
back when he was pretending to have some
semblance of a spine
the woke police are looking for any
opportunity to impose their will and
that's really what this is about
to punish those who deviate uh from the
path
that the the woke mob has prescribed for
all of our lives
and that explains the seemingly sort of
weird fact that oftentimes
the people who defend the canceled
person
will get cancelled even harder than the
original cancel e
it's because the defender is making a
more direct and explicit attack
on the woke mob's tactics and therefore
its authority
even if that attack is still extremely
circumspect and peppered with all kinds
of
qualifiers and clauses and so on as it
was with chris harrison doesn't matter
anyone who dares to speak up and say no
you know
i don't think you guys should be doing
it this way
anyone who does that will get the
harshest treatment of all harrison's
girlfriend knew that
that's why she threw him right on the
bus all the contestants on the show
everybody gets the message right and
that's how this is supposed to work
i said last week that the woke mob uh
takes your scalp once it cancels you
they take the scalp and they nail it to
their wall as a trophy well
that i was actually wrong that's
actually not exactly correct
i think it's truer to say that they take
off your head
and they put it on a pike and leave it
on the outskirts of town
as a warning to any other challengers
that's really what what it is
it's ruthless it's bloodthirsty and it's
extremely effective and to stand up to
them
to really stand up against them to
really defy them
will take a lot more courage and
backbone than the host of the bachelor
apparently possesses no big surprise
there i suppose
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content